hello readers i'm here in the legendary
study of the famous fictional dog
detective sherlock bones of 221b barker
street
mr bones you're here to teach me about
using details from a text to make
inferences aren't you yes my boy it's
simplicity itself but first let me
deduce a few things about you shall i
well mr bones were trying to do this
about writing not about people so give
me your hand
ah you like to cook you have a nervous
disposition and you work for khan
academy now how did you know that
you have a callous on your finger from
how you hold a knife your fingernails
are bitten not clipped and your
messenger bag says khan academy well and
i told you who i was before i showed up
that too but what does this have to do
with reading a book i correctly deduce
several truths about your person based
on clues my good david indeed all
inference is making sense of clues when
you read a story you are constantly
making inferences i see
okay i'll read a passage and then see
what i can make of it
an hour later thick smoke poured up the
stairs the smoke detector screamed and i
could hear uncle paleo stumbling around
with the fire extinguisher when he came
upstairs afterward his footsteps sounded
slow and heavy he was a wreck broken
glasses black smudges on his face and
singed hair
okay so i can surmise that there was
some kind of fire or explosion
downstairs where the character uncle
paleo was
hmm how do you know well his hair was
singed that's another word for burned
and his face was covered in black
smudges like you'd get from soot from a
fire and there was all the smoke and the
smoke detector went off
and there is also the matter of the fire
extinguisher also that
i see something else in that passage too
what's that mr bones uncle paleo was
exhausted by putting out the fire how
can you tell where does it say that
well it doesn't that's inference my lad
note here how it says his footsteps
sounded slow and heavy why might that be
he stepped in something sticky no
he's wearing shoes made of lead well
those are indeed possible explanations
but you want to think of the most likely
option he was running around to put the
fire out and it made him tired so you
were reading between the lions were you
drawing conclusions from the text i was
so we know for sure uncle paleo was
tired right we do not sir oh an
inference is only one possible
conclusion but is not the only
conclusion so what are we to do well the
more clues you discover the stronger
your influences will become you have to
look at what you already know about a
character about the setting of the story
the events of a story's plot and piece
it together from there you know that
fires create lots of black dust or soot
so it strengthens your argument in favor
of a fire and it's background knowledge
like that about the way the world works
that will serve you as a reader and as a
maker of inferences
apply what you know to the world of the
story and make inferences based on that
and then i can become the world's
greatest consulting detective you can
become like the world's 50th greatest
consulting detective top of the heap's
rather full i'm afraid well thank you
for your time today mr bones best of
luck with your case work thank you i
shan't need it
you can learn anything
dave it out
you